ihr habt nach einer tour durch meinen
gewächshaus gefragt da ist das gute
schätzchen und ich nehme euch gerne mal
mit und zeige euch was wir da drin
anbauen wie das gewächshaus aufgebaut
ist wie wieder die lüftung geregelt
haben uns heute also kommt man mit so
sieht es aus wenn man reinkommt hier
hängt erst mal mein ganzer knoblauch den
wir dieses jahr geerntet haben und den
ich für die einlagerung hier erstmal
trocknen lassen und hier haben wir ein
rundumblick was ich erwartet ein dummer
ein dschungel vor allem dahin gibt es
auch noch weiter dann wären noch mehr
knoblach das funktioniert übrigens super
guten mit dem knoblauch hier den im
gewächshaus zu trocknen ich hatte erst
sorge dass es ein bisschen zu feucht
wäre das hier zu viel schwitzwasser ist
aber der wird super und der lässt sich
super lange lagern so wie es letztes
jahr zum ersten mal gemacht den hier zu
trocknen und der knoblauch hat sich so
lange gelagert wie noch nie vorher
fangen wir mal gleich hier an die haben
wir eine paprika
eigentlich wollte ich da eine andere
sorte hin pflanzen aber irgendwie habe
ich die schilder beim vorziehen
vertauscht hier drüben hat es glaube ich
geklappt dass es die paprika die und
wächst haus anbauen wollte aber die sie
mir doch arg nach freiland paprika als
die wer draußen auch wunderbar gewachsen
und dann eben kennt ihr diese pflanze
hier das ist eine monster ich habe mich
gerade auch sehr darüber gewundert dass
die hier steht die hatte ich nämlich
eigentlich für unser wurzelwerk büro
gekauft meine mitarbeiterin jackie und
ich sind schon ganz aufgeregt und wollen
sie zu einer monströsen größe heran
ziehen und ein praktikant wollte die
heute umtopfen da hat es wohl nicht mehr
geschafft und sie hier abgestellt da und
höre mir noch basilikum
da sieht nicht gut aus das wurde
angeknabbert wir haben es erst vor
kurzem gepflanzt also von der größe her
ist es okay aber irgendwas macht ihm zu
schaffen und ich glaube es ist ihm auch
ein bisschen trocken hier drin weil ich
nicht so oft zum gießen kommen ja dann
haben wir hier ungefähr 30
tomatenpflanzen drin von ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen sorten
ich finde auch die machen so schöne
blüten oder schaut euch das mal an es
nicht unglaublich schön es ist immer
eine superschöne zeit im jahr wenn die
erste tomatenernte kommt weil wir ja im
winter keine tomaten essen oder nur ganz
ganz ganz selten mal welche im laden
kaufen und dann immer super enttäuscht
sind weil sie sowieso nicht schmecken
und deswegen freuen wir uns immer enorm
wenn die ersten früchte gut werden
und ich habe ein riesen glück dass ich
hier gerade eine wäsche waschen kann nur
einen sohn hat hier schon alles
geplündert
schaut euch mal diese ist an diesen
wirklich riesig das ist eine ananas
tomate einer meiner aktiven
lieblingssorten eine sehr sehr leckere
gelbe fleischtomate super ertragreich
macht riesen große früchte
wir haben auch schon welche geerntet die
doppelt so groß sind wie die hier also
wirklich eine ganz tolle sehr
empfehlenswerte sorte hier ist auch noch
eine ziemlich große wir sie super super
empfehlung
[Musik]
hier haben wir ein phänomen das ist eine
überdüngung tomate ihr seht den anderen
tomaten geht es super aber dieses
exemplar hier sieht wirklich kümmerlich
aus und das liegt aller
wahrscheinlichkeit da noch daran dass
ich die hühner im gewächshaus hatte im
winter die haben hier ihre sitzstange
gehabt und da haben die natürlich immer
ganz gut hingekriegt gefunden dadurch
ist da glaube ich einen riesen
stickstoff phosphor überschuss an dieser
stelle wir haben versucht das mit dem
rechen zu verteilen aber offensichtlich
nicht sehr erfolgreich denn diese
automatisch und ganz schön darunter zu
leiden also wenn ihr euch fragt wie
überdüngten tomaten aussehen die frage
kommt ja immer wieder
das ist ein ziemlich gutes beispiel
voran schaut euch die an so schöne
tomaten die hände reichen auch immer so
toll wenn man hier ist und die ganzen
blätter anfasst wenn man aus gegeizt hat
mein freund kann abends im bett immer
riechen aber ich an dem tag als geister
haben würde nicht mein verlobter noch
nicht ganz du musst mir ersten antrag
machen aber schon sehr romantisch bitte
nicht jetzt
ich arbeite ihr seht wir leiten die
tomaten an solchen schnüren nach oben
das sind kompostierbare schnüre wenn man
die so wenn die tomaten fertig sind im
herbst einfach mitsamt den stühlen auf
den kompost werfen kann und dann
kompostieren die und da wickeln wir das
obere ende der pflanze einfach da komme
ich jetzt schon gar nicht mehr dran um
das euch zu demonstrieren wickeln das um
die stimmung so dass die tomate dann
halt an der schnur findet die ist unten
einmal um die pflanze drum unbefestigt
seht ihr hier da habe ich das fest
geknotet in der lockeren schlaufe und so
ziehen sich die fäden von da oben von
dem treten die wir da oben gespannt
haben bis nach unten durch und die
tomaten haben halt
ihr seht da oben haben wir noch ein
bisschen spiel gelassen so dass wir die
tomaten wenn sie oben ankommen noch
runter lassen können dann können wir die
unteren blätter entfernen und die
tomaten hängen ein bisschen auf den
boden wie verrutschen die dann immer ein
bisschen so dass die noch weiter wachsen
können und wir noch mehr tomaten ernten
können hier wächst übrigens ein kürbis
zwischen meinen tomaten der ist da
einfach aus dem kompost raus gekommen
den wir verwendet haben
der macht sich hier ganz schön breit
leute leute unglaublich der wächst auch
hier bis an die decke
natürlich nimmt er den tomaten
nährstoffe platz und licht weg aber
irgendwie kann ich mich nicht überwinden
ihn rauszureißen weil ja geht euch das
auch so ich kriege so irgendwie nicht
gebacken ich bringe es nicht übers herz
den pflanzen was anzutun hier haben wir
lüftungsklappen das ist natürlich ganz
ganz wichtig in einem gewächshaus dass
es gut durchlüftet ist das ist im winter
wichtig und das ist im sommer wichtig
und da haben wir hier also der kürbisse
das jetzt ganz schön in beschlag
genommen aber hier haben wir regel an
denen kann man die leistung auf und zu
machen
es ist sehr hochwertig das ganze
gewächshaus ist es natürlich auch ein
schickes teures teil gewesen man muss
natürlich nicht so viel geld gewächshaus
ausgeben mir war es wichtig dass es ein
glas gewächshaus ist das heißt dass ich
keine stegplatten habe die sehr schnell
trüb werden und das ist ein hochwertiges
gewächshaus ist aber niemand muss sich
so ein gewächshaus anschaffen
einfach nur um gemüse anzubauen das wird
sich niemals auszahlen was wir hier an
gemüse in dem gewächshaus ernten können
da oben haben wir auch noch lüftungen da
haben wir auch viel stück also da eine
da eine und da hinten auch noch zwei
anni im giebel da oben sind auch noch
zwei siegen da nie eines da und die sind
super praktisch weil die ja diese öffne
haben und die können sich automatisch
öffnen und schließen je nachdem wie warm
es hier drin ist das heißt da ist ein
wachstum das sich ausbreitet und
zusammenzieht so dass das gewächs aus
was die oberen fenster angeht immer
automatisch belüftet ist da kann man
auch einstellen
wie sensibel das auf die temperatur
reagieren soll
und das macht super viel aus also unten
die klappen lasse ich eigentlich immer
offen egal ob sommer oder winter das
wieder meine überdüngt tomate die sind
wirklich arm aus oder mal gucken ob sie
noch irgendwann ein paar früchte machen
möchte hat da hat sie eine aber darüber
heute jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
sprechen also diese lüftungen hier die
dass ich eigentlich immer offen so dass
immer eine gute durchlüftung herrscht
außer in ganz ganz kalten nächten da
mache ich die mal zu aber auch im winter
ist es total wichtig dass das
gewächshaus richtig gut belüftet ist
also normalerweise lasse ich die auch
den ganzen winter über offen das ist
wichtiger für die pflanzen als der
schutz vor der kälte
das gewächshaus hat regenrinnen wir
haben nur noch keine regentonnen
deswegen steht hier ein eimer deswegen
in dem moment sowieso nicht aber wenn es
dann mal regnet ist das super praktisch
das wasser da hier im garten zu haben
und dann auch den verwenden zu können um
das gewächshaus zu gießen
die scheiben sind zugegebenermaßen ganz
schön dreckig ich habe mich noch nicht
dazu überwinden können hier fenster zu
putzen aber ich denke diesen winter ist
das auf jeden fall mal fällig damit es
im frühling dann wieder richtig hübsch
aussieht hier ist auch noch ein bisschen
basilikum und das ist auch ganz schön
angefressen und ich weiß jetzt wer die
übeltäter waren nennen ich habe eben ein
paar schnecken hier im gewächshaus
entdeckt die sich unter einer anzucht
schale versteckt hatten aber da war auch
ein tiger schlegel dabei ich habe den
für euch gefilmt den blende ich euch
jetzt nur einen tigers nägel sind kleine
kirchen wie getigert sind das sind
sozusagen die raubtiere unter den
schnecken die pressen andere schnecken
das heißt wenn man tiger schlegel im
garten findet immer vor ihn nicht
wegmachen nicht töten die sind super die
kerle und ich habe letztens eine in
unserem garten angesiedelt den ich
unterwegs gefunden habe kann ich euch
noch mal bilder ein
landon mich gefreut dass ich den
gefunden haben
[Musik]
offensichtlich haben hier trotzdem ein
paar schnecken an unserem basilikum
pflanzen herum geknabbert
das da sind übrigens meine erdnuss
pflanzen ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
erinnert ich habe ja im frühling
erdnüsse gesellt und das experiment
verläuft prächtig wie ihr sehen könnt
nicht herren ich weiß nicht was mit
denen los ist aber die haben seit ich
sie gepflanzt habe eigentlich nichts
gemacht außer schlecht auszusehen
vielleicht die sich sie zu wenig erzählt
mal wieder aussehen falls ihr auch
welche pflanzt habt aber das ist eine
richtige enttäuschung deswegen habe ich
auch schon länger nichts mehr über die
erzählt weil ich weiß gar nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll und ich weiß auch nicht
woran es liegt vielleicht daran dass es
im gewächshaus ist aber meine im
freiland sind eigentlich alle gestorben
also den hier geht es noch
verhältnismäßig gut
im vergleich zu den vier stück die ich
ins freiland gepflanzt habe und die alle
verstorben sind
ich hoffe die tour hat euch gefallen
durch meine tomaten dschungel hier das
gewächshaus ist von der firma robinson
ich werde dafür nicht bezahlt dass ich
dieses video machen nur dass ihr das
wisst wie gesagt das sind sehr teure
hochwertige gewächshäuser ich bin
absolut zufrieden aber ich finde es auch
ein bisschen extrem dafür so viel geld
auszugeben
ich habe mir das irgendwie schon so
lange gewünscht und habe mir irgendwann
gedacht ja andere leute kaufen sich ein
teures auto dann spare ich lieber auf
ein schickes gewächshaus das war dann so
meine rechtfertigung aber wie gesagt ein
günstigeres gewächshaus tut es genauso
ein selbst gebautes gewächshaus hat
vielleicht sogar noch viel mehr charme
aber ich bin super zufrieden mit meinem
gewächshaus ich liebe es ich liebe es
jetzt zeit zu verbringen ich finde es
auch im winter super schön hier drin zu
sein wenn es einfach fünf grad 10 grad
manchmal sogar noch wärmer ist als
draußen das macht ja das gärtnern im
winter einfach noch viel angenehmer man
hat natürlich auch im winter noch viel
mehr möglichkeiten gemüse anzubauen wenn
man ein gewächshaus hat und auch im
frühling und die tomaten fühlen sich
sehr wohl wenn ihr meine anderen tomaten
tipps anschauen wollt weil ich euch mal
da oben die playlist es ist ein tolles
gewächshaus
bin rundum zufrieden es ist ja ein traum
und es macht super viel spaß hier drin
zeit zu verbringen und zu gärtnern und
ich werde jetzt auf die suche gehen nach
ein paar roten tomaten das ist immer gar
nicht so einfach wenn mein sohn vor mir
da war und hoffentlich ein paar finden
und wünsche euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag wenn ihr wollt
verlinkt ihr euch euch da trieben und da
unten videos die euch auch interessieren
könnten ansonsten freue ich mich wenn
ihr ein abo oder einen daumen nach oben
da last wir sehen uns nächste woche
wieder distanziert
ich habe tatsächlich noch eine gefunden